a
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola compañeros estadounidenses
y bueno el pueblo desde la web
veo mi compañero al senador tom que
apretará y quiero agradecer al senador
también creo que el gobernador también
está ahí
esa es nuestra más importante mi hermana
el valor y bueno
no importa señores damas el pueblo de
esa nación ha hablado
ellos nos entregaron un mensaje una
victoria clara una victoria convincente
una victoria
para nosotros el pueblo hemos ganado con
la mayor cantidad de votos que alguna
vez votada en la historia del país 74
millones
[Aplausos]
creo que debo admitir que me sorprendió
esta noche se puede ver en todo el país
todas las ciudades todas partes del país
incluso en todo el mundo una gran
grandes por de alegría de esperanza fue
renovada en el futuro y en un nuevo día
y me enorgullece la confianza que
ustedes me dieron a mí yo prometo ser un
presidente que busque no dividir sino
unificar que no vea estados rojos ni
azules solamente a los eeuu
trabajar con todo mi corazón con la
confianza de todo el pueblo ganar la
confianza de todos ustedes y por ello es
que creo que eeuu trata de la gente es
eso es lo que buscar en nuestra
administración yo busque este cargo para
restaurar el alma de eeuu para
reconstruir la columna vertebral de esta
nación la clase media y hacer que eeuu
sea respetada alrededor del mundo de
nuevo
no crecieron
que estemos unidos aquí en casa
verlos aquí honra el trabajo de mi vida
a ver que tantos millones de
estadounidenses votaron por esa visión
ahora el trabajo de hacer esa misión
real es una tarea es la tarea de nuestra
era caballeros como lo he dicho muchas
veces antes
soy el esposo de jill
[Aplausos]
y no estaría acá sin su amor sin su
apoyo incansable el de giles también el
de dijo hunter y de ashley mi hija y de
todos nuestros nietos y sus esposas y
toda nuestra familia
está en mi corazón
es una madre del ejército también es una
educadora se ha dedicado en toda su vida
a educar pero no se trata de lo que haga
sino de quién es para él para los
educadores de estadounidenses esto es un
día importantísimo
ustedes van a tener a uno de ustedes en
la casa blanca y yale va a ser que seas
quien va a ser una que era la primera
dama y me enorgullece muchísimo
[Aplausos]
todos entrar en honor de servir con una
fantástica vicepresidente acaba de
escuchar a cámara harris
qué hace historia como la primera mujer
la primera mujer negra la primera mujer
de descendencia del sur de asia la
primera hija de emigrantes elegida en
este país
no me digan que no es posible en los
eeuu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ya era bien debido y se nos recuerda hoy
a aquellos que lucharon tan fuerte por
tantos años para hacer que esto
sucediera de nuevo eeuu ha marcado más
la justicia moral del mundo cámara y dog
que era lo no su familia se están como
se están convirtiendo en un baile en oro
horarios y no tienen salida de esto a
todos aquellos que fueron voluntarios
que trabajaron en las urnas en medio de
esta pandemia los funcionarios elegidos
localmente ustedes merecen un
agradecimiento especial de todo el país
[Aplausos]
mi equipo de campaña todos los
voluntarios ahí todos dieron tanto de sí
mismo para hacer que este momento fuera
posible y yo les debo les debo muchísimo
y les debo todo a todos aquellos que nos
respaldaron
me enorgullece la campaña que
construimos me enorgullece la comisión
que reunimos la más amplia la más
diversa en la historia demócratas
republicanos independientes progresistas
moderados conservadores jóvenes viejos
urbanos urbanos rurales
lg bt y latinos asiáticos nativos
estadounidenses
estoy hablando en serio especialmente en
estos momentos especialmente en esos
momentos donde la campaña estuvo en su
momento más bajo la jurista de unidense
estuvo ahí por mí
siempre estuvieron sosteniendo me y yo
los respaldará
[Aplausos]
y yo lo dije al principio quiero
representar a esta campaña quiero que
esta campaña represente y luzca como
eeuu y hemos hecho eso ahora queremos
que la administración sea así para todos
ustedes que votaron por el presidente
trump y yo entiendo la decepción hoy he
perdido varias un par de veces yo pero
ahora hay que darnos a otro uno a otro
una oportunidad
[Aplausos]
es momento de pasar a un lado la
retórica agresiva bajar la temperatura
vernos el uno al otro escucharnos el uno
al otro de nuevo y para lograr progreso
debemos dejar de detener tratar a
nuestros oponentes como nuestros
enemigos ellos no son nuestros enemigos
son estadounidenses son estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
la biblia nos dice que siempre hay una
temporada una temporada de construir una
temporada de cosechar una temporada de
sanar este es el momento de sanar en
eeuu
[Aplausos]
ahora esta campaña se ha acabado cuál es
la voluntad del pueblo cuál es nuestro
mandato yo creo que es este
eeuu nos ha hecho un llamado dis para
marchar junto a las fuerzas de la
decencia de las fuerzas de la justicia
de las fuerzas de las ciencias las
fuerzas de la esperanza en las grandes
batallas de nuestra era la batalla para
controlar el vídeo batalla para
construir la prosperidad la batalla para
asegurar el cuidado de la salud de su
familia la batalla para lograr la
justicia racial y acabar con el racismo
sistemático en nuestro país
y la batalla para salvar nuestro planeta
al hacer que el clima esté bajo control
la batalla para restaurar la decencia
defender la democracia y darle a todos
en este país una oportunidad justa es
todo lo que están pidiendo una
oportunidad justa
y caballeros
todo el trabajo empieza controlando el
cob y 19no podemos reparar la economía
restaurar su vitalidad
o aprecian los momentos hermosos de la
vida abrazar a nuestros nietos sus
cumpleaños graduación todos esos
momentos que nos importan hasta tener
esto bajo control el lunes yo nombraré
un grupo de científicos líderes y
expertos como consejeros transicionales
para ayudar
al llevar el plan de covirán jarvis y
convertirlo en un plano de acción que
restaurará a partir de enero de 2021
restaurará la salud del país ese plan
será construido a través a partir de una
ciencia inamovible será construido para
desde la compasión la apatía y la
preocupación no me ahorraré ningún
ningún esfuerzo ningún compromiso para
dar giro a esta pandemia
damas y caballeros soy un demócrata
orgulloso
pero voy a gobernar como presidente
estadounidense trabajaré tan duro por
aquellos que no votaron por mí así como
por aquellos que lo hicieron
dejemos que esta gris era demonización
en eeuu
empiece a acabarse aquí y ahora
la negativa de demócratas y republicanos
a cooperar en unos con otros no es una
fuerza misteriosa más allá de su control
es una decisión una elección que hacemos
y si podemos elegir no cooperar podemos
elegir cooperar
y yo creo
que esto es parte del mandato que se nos
ha dado por parte de los estadounidenses
ellos quieren que nosotros cooperamos en
su interés y esa es la elección que yo
haré y llamo el congreso demócratas
republicanos por igual que hagan esa
elección conmigo que tomen ese camino la
historia estadounidense
es ampliar lentamente pero firmemente
las oportunidades y aquí no hay ningún
error hay muchos sueños que se han
diferido por mucho tiempo debemos
hacerle la promesa del país una promesa
la promesa de eeuu hacerla real para
todos sin importar su etnicidad su fe o
su identidad o sus incapacidades
caballeros y damas estados unidos
siempre han sido formada por momentos de
inflexión por momentos en el tiempo
donde tomamos decisiones difíciles sobre
quiénes somos y qué queremos ser lincoln
en 1861 salvar a la unión frank quintero
los bed en 1932 prometiendo una liga de
país un nuevo trato john f kennedy en
1960 prometiendo una nueva frontera y 12
hace 12 años cuando barack obama en su
historia y nos dijo que si podíamos
[Aplausos]
damas y caballeros estamos en un punto
de inflexión tenemos una oportunidad de
vencer de construir una nación de
prosperidad y propósito podemos hacerlo
yo sé que podemos he hablado mucho
tiempo de la batalla por el alma de eeuu
debemos restaurar el alma de eeuu
nuestra nación ha sido formada por la
batalla constante entre nuestros
mejores impuestos y nuestros peores
impuestos en presidente no diré que esté
en esta batalla lo que importa es el
tiempo es un momento que lo mejor de
nosotros prevalezca esta noche todo el
mundo está observando eeuu ello creo que
en nuestro mejor momento eeuu es un faro
para el mundo no lideraremos solamente
con el ejemplo
o por el poder de nuestro ejemplo
[Aplausos]
yo sé siempre he creído muchos me han
escuchado decirlo siempre he creído que
podemos definir eeuu en una palabra
posibilidades
eso en eeuu todo el mundo debería tener
oportunidad para llegar tan lejos como
sus sueños y las habilidades dadas por
dios lo lleven vean yo creo en las
posibilidades de este país siempre
estamos mirando hacia el futuro
[Música]
donde un eeuu es más justo más justo
donde se crean trabajos con dignidad y
respeto donde se curen las enfermedades
como cáncer si alzheimer's por eeuu que
no deja a nadie atrás con eeuu un jefe
de eeuu que jamás se rinde más que nunca
se rinde
[Aplausos]
esta es una gran nación siempre ha sido
una lucha contra eeuu pero somos un
pueblo bueno
estos son los estados unidos de américa
nunca ha habido nada
nunca ha visto nunca habido nada que no
hayamos podido hacer cuando lo hayamos
hecho juntos caballeros y damas en los
últimos días de la campaña yo empecé a
pensar sobre algo que significa mucho
para mí y realmente para mi hijo
captura la que me sostiene y creo que es
la misma fe que eso sí en eeuu y la
esperanza una esperanza que esperamos
pueda proveer algún con alguna especie
de libio
para tantos miles de eeuu que perdieron
a un ser querido por este terrible virus
de este año mi corazón va con cada uno
de ustedes esperemos que esta situación
les dé algo de tranquilidad esto es es
el el salmón y él los levantara en las
alas de los ángeles los cargará en el
aliento de la mañana y los hará saludar
al sol y los sostendrá en la palma de su
mano
y ahora juntos
en las alas de los ancones nos enfocamos
en un viaje que que dios nos ha pedido
que hagamos con todo nuestro corazón con
nuestra mano más firme con fe en eeuu y
en cada uno del otro con amor por el
país sed por justicia permítanos ser la
nación que sabemos que podemos ser una
nación unida una nación fuerte una
nación sanada los estados unidos de
américa damas y caballeros
nunca nunca ha habido en los eeuu nada
que hemos intentado ir hayamos podido
hacer así que recuerden como mi abuelo
nuestro abuelo decía cuando salí de su
casa cuando yo era un niño en scranton
decía joey mantén la fe y mi abuela
cuando él estaba vida decían hombre no
lo mantengas disemina la dársela a todo
el mundo dios los ama a todos que dios
bendiga a estados unidos y que dios
proteja a nuestras tropas muchas gracias
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]